(slow piano music)
- [Narrator] This is Goliath,
a Galapagos tortoise.
He is massive.
At over 520 pounds,
he's one of the biggest
tortoises in the world.
Goliath is believed to be in his 80s.
Galapagos tortoises have been
known to live over 150 years.
They can go extended periods of time
without food or water, up to a year.
This unfortunately led
to human exploitation.
Sailors on ships would
bring these slow moving
defenseless giants on long
voyages as a source of meat.
By the 1970s, only about 3,000 were left,
but through conservation
and breeding efforts,
there are now over 20,000.
They've become a flagship species
for conservation efforts
throughout the Galapagos.
But poaching and habitat loss
are still a very real threat.
This is the Galapagos tortoise.
(slow piano music)